I
LED
OUT
THERE TAKING PICTURES OF JURORS.
PEOPLE ARE WATCHING.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THEM, TAKING
NAMES.
IT'S GOT TO BE SOME OF THEIR
MINDS.
>> PRESSURE TACTICS.
COVERING TRIALS, YOU NEVER KNOW
UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN IN THAT
COURTROOM EVERY D AND SEEN
EVERY PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT THE
JURY HAS SEEN AND EVERY
ARGUMENT, EVERY WITNESS THAT THE
JURORS HAVE SE, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THE TAKE-AWAY IS UNLESS
YOU'RE IN THERE EVERY DAY,
NUMBER 1.
>> NUMBER 2, YOU TALKED ABOUT
JOE BIDEN PILING ON AND CALLING
LE RITTENHOUSE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST THAT NEEDED TO BE I.
THIS IS WHEN HE WAS RUNNING AS A
UNER.
AIN, THE SIGNS WERE THERE HOW
EASILY HE CAVED THERE TO THE
LEFT WING AND THE PROGRESSIVES
AS HE IS NOWS, AS HE GOT IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
CALLED THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
AND CALLED THEM OUT FOR WHIPPING
PEOPLE, WHICH WAS A LIE.
HE LIES WITHOUT ANY CONSEQUENCE
AND HE LIES RECKLESSLY,
DANGEROUSLY SO.
BUT THE LEFT FROMOMENT ONE
THAT THIS SHOOTING HAPPENED, NOT
HAVING ANY EVIDENCE, THE LEFT
NEEDED TO REPOSITION KITE
RITTENHOUSE TO REINFORCE THEIR G
FOR JUSTICE.
THEY WERE RIOTING AGAINST WHITE
SUPREMACY AND THE BIGOTS AND
POLICE BRUTALITY.
SO THIS DIDN'T FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE, SO THEY IMMEDIATELY
HAD TO LABEL HI YOU KNOW, WHAT
THEY WANTED HIM TO BE.
ONE MORE THING REAL QUICK.
THERE'S A -- BY THE WAY, KYLE
RITTENHOUSE IS BEING TREATED FOR
PTSD AND IS IN THERAPY ACCORDING
TO HIS DISCUSSION IN THE COURT
TODAY.
BILL ECKMAN IS THIS LIBERAL
HEDGE FUND MANAGER.
HE TWEETED THIS LONG THREAD.
HE SAID LAST NIGHT THIS IS WHEN
RITTENHOUSE WAS TESTIFYING, MY
WIFE AND IATCHED IT AND WE
CAME AWAY BELIEVING THAT KYLE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
OUR FIRST HAND IMPRESSIONS WERE
MATERIALLY DIFFERENT THAN THOSE
THAT WE PREVIOUSLY FORMED BASED
ON OPINION.
LIKE I'M THE SUBJECT OF PRESS
REPORTS.
I KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
HE SAID YET SOMEHOW I CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE OTHER ARTICLES IN THE
SAME NEWAPER ABOUT SUBJECTS
THAT I KNOW LESS WELL.
HE BROUGHT OUT THIS WAS BIAS.
THE END OF T THREAD SAYS I
JUST GOT A CALL FROM THE MEDIA
ASKING IF MY TWITTER ACCOUNT WAS
HACKED
>> Jesse: JESSICA, IT'S LIKE
WHEN YOU READ REPORTSBOUT ME.
WHEN YOU MEET ME IN PERSON, I'M
ADORABLE.
>> Greg: HE IS A DEMON THOUGH.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT FAKE NEWS.
>> WON'T BE DISTRACTED BY WHAT
I NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
>> SO I THINK WHEN YOU USE THE
TERM WHITE SUPREMACIST NOW
UNLESS IT'S LIKE A NEO-NI OR
SOMETHINGIKE THAT PEOPLE TUNE
OUT ON BOTHSIDES.
RIGHT?
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO THINK IT WAS
A WHITE SUPREMACIST, THAT'S
CONFIRMED AND THEY'RE DONE.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE NO, THERE'S AN
ALTERNATIVE EXPLANATION, THEY
HAVE THEIR STORY AS WELL.
THE FACT THAT THIS HAPPENED
SURROUNDING THE SHOOTING OF
JACOB BLAKE BY THE POLICE SEVEN
TIMES IN THE BACK LEAVING HIM
PARALYZED TURNED THIS INTO A
RACE ISSUE NO MATTER WHERE HE
WENT.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A JUSTIFIED
SHOOTING, BY THE WAY.
I WANTO MAKE SURE THE AUDIENCE
KNEW THAT.
>> I'M SUREHEY DO KNOW THAT.
>> Jesse: THEY'RE VERY SMART.
>> I LOVE OUR AUDIENCE.
>> Jesse: NOT AS MUCH AS I DO.
I'M SORRY.
>> I'M GOING TO GET CUT OFF.
SO THAT PUT THIS IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
PROTEST AND ET CETERA AND MADE
IT INTO A RACE ISSUE.
THE DOWN GRADING OF THE CHARGES
IS A GIVE ME FOR THE PROSECUTION
WHO HAD A BAD WEEK.
SO I THINK THAT THAT IS GOING TO
SATISFY A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN WATCHING THIS TRIAL
ERNESTLY AND SAYING, OKAY, THIS
LOOKS LIKE IT'S SELF-DEFENSE.
I'M STILL NOT WILLING TO SAY A
KID THAT LIVES ACROSS STATE
LINES AND GET AN AR-15 AND GOES
INTO A PLAY HE DOESN'T LIVE TO
HELPUT ON THE POLICE SIDE WENT
THERE WITH PERFECT INTENTIONS.
HE WASN'T ON HIS PROPERTY.
HE WANTED TO INTERVENE IN
SOMETHING THAT HE DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE ANY BUSINESS BEING IN.
THAT WILL NOT BE LO.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO -- I LIVE
ACROSS STATE LINES, YOU KNOW?
I CROSS A FEW WHEN I COME HERE.
I GO FROM NEW YORK, CONNECTICUT.
IT'S LIKE -- HE'S REALLY CLOSE
TO KENOSHA.
HE'S DAD LIVES THERE.
PARENTSLY GOES THERE A LOT.
I THINK THE STATE LIN THING, I
MEAN, IT'S NOT LIKE A BORDER.
OKAY?
>> Jesse: IS A BUZZ WORD.
>> Greg: LET'S BUILD A WALL.
>> YOU DON'T BORROW YOUR
FRIEND'S GUNS TO DRIVE THROUGH
CONNECTICUT.
IT'S DIFFERENT TO DRIVE INTO A
RIOT.
>> Greg: IF YOU'RE IN A RIOT,
MAYBE SO WHEN YOU'RE WATCHING
WHATS GOING ON AND THERE'S NO
POLICE.
>>
>> Martha: WHEN YOU GO BACK AND
WATCH THE VIDEO OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN KENOSHA, STORES GETTING FIRE
BOMBED AND THIS WOMAN THAT I
TALKED TO WHO HAD A MATTRESS
STORE AND HER EMPLOYEES GOT HIT
IN THE HEAD WITH A BRICK.
YOU HAVEO PUT YOURSELF IN THAT
MOMENT TO UNDERSTAND THE FULL
CONTEXT HERE.
HE DIDN'T GO OH, I THINK I'LL
DRIVE TO KENOSHA WITH MYRIFLE.